رياح شعبيه تيك توك والتطبيقات الصينيه
الاخرى تجري بما لا تشتهي سفينه واشنطن
جهود الاحتواء عادت بنتائج عكسيه تطبيقات
صينيه انتشرت بين المستخدمين الامريكيين
بشكل كبير في الفتره الاخيره منصه
ابتكرتها الشركه المالكه لتيك توك
الامر يتعلق بتطبيق الذي يجمع ميزات
تطبيقات اخرى وهو موجه لفئه الشباب
والمراهقين تطبيق يستخدمه حوالي مليون
وثمانمائه الف شخص شهريا فضلا عن تطبيق
كاب كات المخصص لتوضيب المقاطع المصوره
والذي يستخدمه 99 مليون شخص اضافه الى
منصه التجاره الالكترونيه شيء ب 855 مليون
عمليه تنزيل في الولايات المتحده منذ
بدايته على الرغم من ان التقديرات تشير
الى حوالي 22 مليون مستخدم نشط شهريا
وتيميو الذي حقق المرتبه ضمن متجر ابل
بسبعه وستين مليون مستخدم تشترك هذه
التطبيقات في بعض الميزات التي اثارت قلق
الحكومه الامريكيه مع تيك توك حول ما اذا
كانت هذه الشركات تحمي بيانات المستخدم
الامريكي غير ان الخبراء يقولون ان هناك
اختلافات مهمه بين هذه التطبيقات وتيك توك
ما قد يفسر النقص النسبي في الاهتمام بها
من بين اهم هذه الامور حجم وجود هذه
التطبيقات في الولايات المتحده الى غايه
الان الذي لا يضاهي حجما انتشار التيك توك
تطبيقات تحقق انتشارا متناميا بين صفوف
الامريكيين في وقت تسعى الولايات المتحده
لمواجهه منصه تيك توك بسبب ما تعتبره
تهديدا لامنها القومي غير ان خبراء
امريكيين يدعمون فكره خلق بدائل منافسه
للتطبيقات الصينيه قصد مواجهتها والحد من
انتشارها بلال البشتين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات